be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly what's going on guys this is
Robin and welcome to Marvel where to
start a series where I give you a
suggested reading list for various
Marvel characters and teams based on my
experience now keep in mind this is not
designed to replace full character
discussions and it's not designed for
these opinions to be absolute these
videos are designed to help you decide
which stories are worth reading and this
week we're going to be talking about
daredevil
[Music]
[Applause]
so daredevil volume 1 issue number 1
from 1964 is essential read for anyone
starting with daredevil because this
gives us the first origin of daredevil
and in truth this is specifically
important when it comes to later stories
like Frank Miller's run on daredevil and
daredevil yellow now the origin has us
given to us in this story is that Matt
Murdock's father is a boxer and as a
boxer he decides not to throw a fight
which results in him being killed by a
mobster
now this ultimately leads to daredevil
taking on the role of becoming a
superhero but the way his character is
initially depicted to us is that he's
designed his suit which is yellow and
black based on the boxing uniform of his
father now with issues number 5 through
10 in volume 1 the writing duties which
were force initially handed by is
handled by Stan Lee were handed over to
Gene Colan and Gene Colan was
responsible for introducing Daredevils
run with the red cast in which of course
appeared in issue number 7 but most of
the story elements that we had seen with
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby's run remains
the same that is to say a lot of the
1960s elements that we had seen in these
stories don't really change that much we
see them battling the same kind of
villains we see them confronting in the
same kind of fashion but things don't
really change it off what we initially
seen now from here we jump to Frank
Miller's run on daredevil with issue
number 168 of volume 1
now during Frank Miller's run daredevil
takes on a much darker tone to the
stories including attempting to murder
criminals and some pretty shady tactics
in terms of trying to gain information
but this run of daredevil is notable
because it was an extreme break away
from what we had seen in previous
daredevil stories where he would
maintain the archetype of a superhero
without delving into the realm of an
antihero and what I mean by this is that
when he operated as a good guy when he
operated as a superhero he was the
archetype of a superhero that is to say
he fought the good fight and he never
really resorted to shady tactics here
but under Frank Miller he was more of a
representation of how gritty a superhero
would have to be in this I guess in
Hell's Kitchen in order to operate
effectively and so what he had done was
effectively turned daredevil into an
antihero now with issues number 238 to
& Nicolson T takes over riding for
daredevil and under an Nichols into the
darker elements of daredevil remain but
their expanded into the
of more real-world issues as a way to
kind of raise awareness for these things
now some fans who were longtime readers
of daredevil initially criticized and
ago Sinti for turning a daredevil into a
series of political platforms but what
really was going on here was that the
idea of an Nicko Sinti was to again keep
the elements of daredevil in a very dark
tone but to also add in elements of the
real world to really depict this
character and what he would be like if
he existed in the real world now the
important thing to also keep in mind
here is that a lot of the elements that
will exist in the Netflix series will
most likely be drawn from both Frank
Miller's Run and Ann Nichols Inti's run
of daredevil and so it's very important
that if you read any of the items on
this reading list you probably catch up
with these two things with that being
said we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys I do peace
[Music]